[Ken] Dog!
[Pewds] Hes peeing on the floor!
[Pewds] Biscuit no!!!
[Pewds] Bad! Bad dog!
[Pewds] AAAAAA! I fell in it! Oh shit! Oh you're drowning in it..!
[Pewds] Oh no ma wife!
[Pewds] My- AHHHHHHHH
[Ken] So.. We have to be..
[Ken] We gotta be the husband and lover right? Thats all we got.
[Pewds] Thats all you got, look at the characters, select the character
*pewds chuckle*
*chuckling intestifies* [Ken] Yeah
*ken laughing* [Pewds] Lover, Wife
[Pewds] Husband.. [Ken] The dog! [Pewds] Or a dog..
[Pewds] Okay, I'll be uh...
[Pewds] I'll be uh.... Lover.
[Pewds] Oh my gaaad! I just had sex with no one!
[Ken] Is somebody in my house having sex with no ne?!
[Pewds] Aw shit I hope the dog doesn't catch me
[Pewds] Oh I got the keys, okay.
[Pewds] What am I doing in this game? Oh-
[Ken] Where are you? [Pewds] You'll never find me
[Pewds] Yes
*ken laughing*
[Pewds] Fuck yeah i'll bail it- AHH NOO I-
*pewds screaming* [Ken] Are you serious?!
[Pewds] I broke all my legs! [Ken] What?!
[Ken] Wha- [Pewds] I jumped from the balcony!
[Pewds] Oh god [Ken] Okay! [Pewds] Oh God
[Pewds] My god, fuck, I found the keys last time..
[Pewds] I have a banana, its okay.
[Ken] PEWDIEPIE YOU IN MY HOUSE?!
[Pewds] OHHHH SHITTTT [Ken] ARE YOU IN MY HOUSE?!?!
[Pewds] Nah, get all the bananas
[Ken] You better not be taking my bananas!!
[Pewds] Fuck the bananas make me slow, shit
[Ken] Where the fuck are you?!
[Pewds] Wait, you're in the wrong bedroom boi
[Ken] OHH
[Ken] Not my daughters (wife??) bedroom!
[Pewds] Eh, *SCREAM*
(turn ur volume down)
[Ken] COME HERE (inaudible)
[Pewds] No! Eat the banana!
[Ken] Ow banana!
[Pewds] YEEEAHHH GOT EM WITH THE BANANA TRICK
[Ken] Where'd you go?
[Pewds] The good ol' banana trick! Fuck you man!
[Pewds] Oh
[Pewds] Ey- Hey officer, STAY IN YOUR GROUND OFFICER
[Ken] Uh Oh! DON'T SELL ME BRO
[Pewds] YEAH THATS RIGHT YOU BETTA WATCH OUT
[Pewds] YOU- NO- NOT A- NOT A STEP CLOSER
[Ken] GET OUTTA MY HOUSE [Pewds] NOT A STEP CLOSER
[Ken] GET ON OUTTA HERE YA HIPPIE
[Pewds] I FUCKED YOUR WIFE BITCH
[Pewds] YEAHHHH *ken screaming or smthn*
[Pewds] THATS RIGHT MUTHA FUCKAAA
[Pewds] banana peel
[Pewds] BANANA PEEL
[Pewds] BANANA
[Ken] I'm tired(?) of your bananas!
[Ken] IVE BEEN MARIO KART I NOW HOW THIS GOES
[Pewds] Uh- fuck- AH STOP HURTING ME [Ken] pUSSY
[Ken] Sonovabitch!
[Ken] *inaudible* banana peels everywhere!
[Ken] AHHH! FUCK
[Ken] Banana peel!
[Pewds] What was that sound?!
[Ken] Those were on the stairs?!
*ken screaming* [Pewds] YEAHHHHH
[Ken] Bro! Don't taze me bro!
[Pewds] I tazed you [Ken] *inaudible* the stairs
[Pewds] Fuck where are my clothessss
[Pewds] Yeah no, you're rich [Ken] GET OUT OF MY LAUNDRY ROOM (isnt that a closet) *pewds scream*
[Pewds] AH SHIT FUCK aHH (what happened to FFF felix) [Ken] GET OUT BITCH
[Pewds] aH- I didn't- I'm innocent!
[Pewds] I FOUND THE KEYS!
[Pewds] I FOUND THE KEYS!!!!! x2 [Ken] Don't touch my donuts! x2
[Pewds] YEAHHHHH [Ken] NO!!
[Pewds] YEAHHH BITCH!! [Ken] You can't get out of the gate! NO!
[Ken] No!! NO!! [Pewds] FUCK YOU!! [Ken] You cant!!
[Ken] Thats what you get for sleeping with my daughter!! (WIFE????)
[Pewds] But it was your wife! (exactly)
[Kens] DUN DUN DUUUNN!
[Pewds] Alright should we switch roles? [Ken] Alright.
[Pewds] Good game!
[Ken] Yeah that was a good game, good game.  [Pewds] Good game
[Pewds] Should of given him a Pepsi ( ;
[Pewds] Who did you invite in my house Marzia!
[Ken] *Marzia voice* Oh no Felix (Pewds) no one!
[Ken] *Marzia voice* No one is here ( ;
[Pewds] God dammit Marzia
[Ken] You'll never find me
[Ken] Fuck, oh god shit
[Pewds] Is that CinnamonTo-
[Pewds] What was that?! x2
[Pewds] Huh?
(turn down your volume)
[Pewds] NOOO!! BANANA!!!
*kens evil laugh though*
[Ken] GOT HIS ASS [Pewds] IM GONNA BEAT THE SHIT OUT OF YOU
[Pewds] BOI [Ken] FUCK!
[Ken] AHHHH NO
*inhuman sound*
[Pewds] AINT NO BANANAS GONNA SAVE YOU
[Pewds] Oh that was way too easy!! What the fuck!
[Pewds] I thought I was just damaging you
[Ken] I was trying to get you to step on the banana in the middle of the floor but you kept going around it
[Pewds] Aw fuck, its gotta be a fresh banana
[Pewds] Lets do that again!
[Pewds] Where are you, you sonovabitch
[Pewds] Marzia! I love you! Why'd you do this?!
[Ken] *Marzia voice* Felix I don't love you anymore
[Pewds] No!!
[Ken] *Marzia voice* You do not like my spaghetti
[Pewds] I don't believe that thats you Marzia! When I found you-
[Ken] *Marzia voice* What are you talking about Felix
[Pewds] This game is so lackluster with two because clearly theres supposed to be like a cheater or whatever
[Pewds] Where the fuck are you?
[Ken] i'M NO- I mean *cough* I'm nowhere.
[Ken] Uhh
[Pewds] What? Marzia!
[Pewds] NO!
[Pewds] Hey! Hey you can't hit this i'm strafing!
[Pewds] I'm strafing! You can't hit this! (Strafing means moving side to side)
[Pewds] Fuck you! Fuck you man! [Ken] I'm timed out
[Pewds] The fuck you timed-
[Ken] AHH!
[Pewds] Bitch, you missed!
[Pewds] BITCH YOU DEAD NOW
[Pewds] AHH BANANA PEEL! *ken laughing*
[Pewds] DAMMIT! Oh you trapped now! [Ken] I'M STUCK I CANT MOVE
[Pewds] Uh, fuck, kids room
[Pewds] Theres the keys actually
[Ken] Oh wow
[Pewds] KIDDING! BI- [Ken] AH! [Pewds] no i'm just kdding [Ken] BANANA!
[Ken] You made me dra- You made me poop a banana out [Pewds] Did you just fucking banana me man?
[Pewds] Hey, walk over it and see if it does anything
[Ken] I'm immune to bananas.
[Pewds] Wait what the fuck- (turn volume down)
*pewds scream* *ken laughing*
[Pewds] God dammit!
[Ken] Oh heres a doughnut, how about a doughnut?
[Pewds] Can I dough- [Ken] Oh nevermind
[Pewds] Oh you stup- You cold hearted son of a b-
[Pewds] DONT- NO! [Ken] FUCK YOU! [Pewds] DON'T DO IT!
[Pewds] I'm just gonna...
[Pewds] Dude you're not fucking downstairs you fucking asshole!
[Pewds] Looking at the street!
[Pewds] Whats that music? WHYS THERE A BANANA PEEL HERE
[Pewds] I'm walking around now, that banana peel was not there before
[Pewds] You're playing the T.V sonovabitch!
[Pewds] The fuck is it- What are you doing some mindfucking me with your-
[Pewds] GOD DAMN BANANA PEEL
*spooked* [Pewds] OH JAVLA- YOU SCARED ME!
[Pewds] FUCK YOU!
[Pewds] FUUCK YOU
[Pewds] i'M GONNA GET CHA YA MUTHA FUCKAAAA
[Ken] YOU'RE NEVER GONNA CATCH ME COPPER!
[Pewds] WHERE ARE YOU, SONOVABITCH
[Ken] AHH
sick dodging skills mate
[Pewds] FUCK YOU!
[Pewds] OH WAIT WHAT THE FUCK WHERE YOU GOIN?
[Pewds] Where you goin there huh
[Ken] You're so close! [Pewds] Wait
[Pewds] Where the fuck did you go?!
[Pewds] What?!
[Pewds] WHAT?! (im mindblown too)
[Pewds] HES GOT CAMOUFLAGE!
[Ken] I DONT KNOW WHERE IM GOING HERE
[Pewds] STAND STILL BOI
[Ken] NO!
[Ken] (where?) MY CLOTHES AT? WHERE THE KEYS AT?
[Pewds] The clothes are upstairs
[Ken] Where upstairs? [Pewds] Fo-
[Ken] Get out of the way! I cant get out of the door!
[Pewds] Follow me, I'll show- I'll take you to your clothes kind sir
[Ken] Oh :D
[Pewds] Yes, just follow me, yes. There are your pants
[Pewds] Here
[Pewds] Go get them. [Ken] Wh-
[Ken] Wh- Why are my- Why are my pants outside?
[Pewds] Why don't you come and get your pants?
[Pewds] Just get your pants
[Ken] I got my trusty remote control
[Pewds] Well I got a FUCKEN TAZ-
[Pewds] Oh you got a remote control?
[Pewds] You gonna block me with that remote control?
[Ken] Yeah bro, gonna- gonna- AHH
[Pewds] THATS MY FUCKEN REMOTE CONTROL YOU PIECE OF SHIT!
[Ken] I- [Pewds] OH SHIT HES GOT HIS PANTS BACK ON!
[Ken] YEAH!! :D
[Pewds] COME BACK HERE!
[Ken] FUCK! THERES NO-
[Pewds] OH! OH! oH! oHH! ooH! YES! yeS!
[Pewds] Where the fuck did you go?!
[Pewds] BITCH!
[Pewds] Fucken-
[Ken] AHH! AH! I ate my doughnut NOO!
(did he just say my penis)
[Pewds] GOTTEM!
[Pewds] Now, can someone else join? (maybe someone with the name Cry?)
[Ken] If anybody wants to play, you can download this game called Catch A Lover
[Ken] And.. You can play a couple rounds with us for a video.
[Pewds] I'm starting to question...
[Pewds] Your.. Uh... Your audience a bit
[Pewds] Theres 800 people.
[Pewds] Watching a stream. But they won't play.. No one-
[Pewds] OH MY GOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO* ken joining in*OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOooooooooooooooooooooooo
[Pewds] Elliot just wrote "Woof Woof Bitch"
[Ken] Woof woof ( ;
[Pewds] Shut the fuck up Elliot- I'm just kidding
[Pewds] YES
[Pewds] Go! Alright!
[Ken] Oh! Hey baby
[Pewds] Ahh, no no no not hey
[Pewds] More like... Heyy (;
[Ken] Heyy (; those nippes though [Pewds] hallo
[Pewds] Wait don't look at MY nipples, look at...
[Ken] Don't, don't, don't- OH I BE LOOKIN OOH HOO HOO HOO
[Pewds] What? What did you do?
[Ken] OH MYYYYY
[Ken] What are you gonna do with this banana here big boy
[Pewds] Eyyy you like banana?
[Ken] hoho yeah
[Pewds] You like banana? Why don't you come here then?
[Ken] O- Oh- I love- oH YEAH
[Pewds] WHAT? ITS NOT WORKING?
[Ken] OH YEAH i lOVE BANANas
[Pewds] No- Sh
[Pewds] Alright help me find- OH i found a key! Yes!
[Ken] Oh nice!
[Pewds] Alright help me find my clothes!
[Pewds] Dat ass tho ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
[Pewds] That ass though ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) [Ken] You like that?
[Pewds] My pants! I found my shirt!
[Ken] Oh! Where was it?
[Pewds] It was right here!
[Ken] *granny voice???* We've been all over this house making mad *inaudible* love [Pewds] Thats right  yeah you sound abit weird
[Ken] *woman voice???* You just take my husbands doughnut? *GASP*
[Ken] He loves his donuts [Pewds] Get the gun!
[Ken] Look at- [Pewds] Get the gun and shoot him
[Ken] I cant- I cant pick it up, it wont let me
[Ken] I don't know how to use a gun
[Pewds] What the fuck are you good for then?!
[Ken] You can crou- Wait.. Am i crouching?
[Pewds] No, I wouldn't call that crouching
[Ken] Is that a key on the floor?
[Pewds] Its another key.. yeah
[Ken] Those keys..
[Ken] Did you flip the couch over?
[Ken] Oh you'll ruin the *inaudible* (feng shui?)
[Pewds] How did I flip the couch over? [Ken] How could you do this?
[Pewds] Oh shit no!
[Pewds] Woah, what the fuck is with the couch?!
[Ken] Push the couch
[Pewds] Its my line(?) of defense!
[Ken] Oh its the dog! [PEWDS] OH THE DOG! (tag urself i'm pewds)
[Pewds] AHH THE DOG
[Pewds] AHH THE COP [Ken] AHH THE COP
[Pewds] SHOOT THE DOG! (nvm im not pewds anymore)
[Pewds] SHOOT
[Pewds] THEm
[Ken] Come at the door!
[Pewds] I SHOT A DOG !! i sHOT THE DOG (prepare for a new wsj article)
[Ken] *wife voice* HUSBAND NO! HUSBAND! OH HUSBAND!
[Pewds] BANANAS!
bANANAS!
[Ken] The dogs attacking!
[Ken] *woman voice* Oh no!
[Pewds] GOTTEM
[Pewds] GOT THEM
[Ken] Oh so sad
*ken laughing*
[Ken] *wife voice* oH HUSBAND NO DONT DO IT!
[Pewds] OH SHIT (oh shit)
[Pewds] oH SHIT (im shook)
*ken screaming* [Pewds] HOH SHIT
[Ken] HE PUNCHED ME!
[Pewds] OH MY GOD
[Pewds] oH MY GOD
[Pewds] I cant bELIEVE HE KILLED *voice crack* HIS WIFE
*more screaming*
look at the doggo
[Pewds] What the fuck- WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE
[Pewds] OH NICE ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) OH SHIT YOU'RE BACK
[Pewds] sHIT x2
*ken screaming* [Pewds] oH SHIT HE KIL-
[Pewds] WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU?! YOU'RE-
[Ken] OHH THEY'RE HURTING(?) [Pewds] KI-
(is that the sound of a dying whale) [Ken] ooh that ass though
[Ken] Ooh ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
[Pewds] KEEP ATTACKING THEM
[Pewds] I GOT A STUN GUN
[Ken] WHERE IS HE?!
[Pewds] FUCK I MISSED THE DOG
[Pewds] Wheres my fucking pants
[Ken] I thought you love me
[Ken] How could you do this- AHHH
[Pewds] I hear you when you get beaten too you just hear a shmack
[Pewds] Across the room
[Pewds] Its a beautiful sound (all i hear is a new wsj article)
[Pewds] Dude I found four stun guns
[Pewds] If they come here..
*ken laughing* [Pewds] They're fucked
[Pewds] I got tazers [Ken] Their house is so huge, who made this house?!
[Pewds] Whoever lives in this house is fuckin lost *insert english*
[Ken] They gotta be like a murderer- whats that guys name? Holmes or whatever
[Ken] Ow eyyyy..
[Pewds] Fuck, I tried to stun you. Sorry.
[Ken] How dare you!
[Pewds] Alright, Alright.
[Pewds] Alright help me find my god damn pants
*idk what pewds said* [Ken] Biscuit! Bad dog!
[Pewds&Ken] *calling biscuit a bad dog*
[Pewds] Bad dogger! Evil Dogger! Go away!
[Pewds] Biscuit! You're better than this!
[Pewds] Sit!
[Ken] Hes supposed to pee on the floor somehow..
[Ken] Have like a full water thing and you can pee on the floor
[Ken] *something* dog! [Pewds] Oh yeah wait dog come here
[Pewds] Theres water here so the dog can drink the water and then piss
[Pewds] Dog come in here (isn't his name biscuit or elliot or something)
[Ken] You just gotta wait, drink that water!
*groAN
[Pewds] No, don't hit me! For fucks sake
[Ken] Biting your ankles
[Pewds] Drink the water you stupid dogger
[Ken] Drink the water dog!
[Ken] Drink the- Oh
[Pewds] Oh
[Ken] Oh
[Pewds] Oh [Ken] Oh
*screaming and laughing*
[Pewds] Beat the wife! The wife did it!
[Pewds] You're supposed to take off the egg(?)
[Ken] Dog!
[Pewds] Hes peeing on the floor!
[Pewds] Biscuit no!
*disciplining biscuit*
[Pewds] AGHHH I FELL IN IT
[Pewds] OH SHIT- OH YOU'RE DROWNING IN IT
[Pewds] NO MY WIFE!
[Pewds] MY- AHHHH * ken screaming *
*pewds screaming* [Ken] HUSBAND PLEASE!
*more screaming*
*and.. more screaming* [Ken] Oh no!
[Pewds] Nooo!
[Ken] boobs though!
And that kids..
Is how I met your mother -_-